que alexis poulain cofondateur du média
le monde moderne bonsoir d'expo l'un
également avec nous en direct pour la
partie si j'ose dire plus médical le
docteur élise clément frottons ce
médecins infectiologues à la pitié
salpêtrière à paris merci madame d'être
en direct avec nos également sur rt
france la première question s'adresse à
vous alexis poulain emmanuel macron on
voit vraiment sur tous les fronts en ce
moment elle est pas d'un jour l'hôpital
necker ce matin et là la conférence de
presse c'est très important qu'ils
occupent le terrain il joue gros et pas
le théâtre et le café joyeux entre que
le commerce
on n'a jamais vu autant dehors c'est
incroyable alors qu' on parle de
confinement là c'est tout l'inversé qui
se passe avec emmanuel macron oui il
veut montrer qu'il est le capitaine en
période de tempête et qu'il est là pour
gérer le bateau france rassuré les
investisseurs les touristes les français
dire que les mesures sont là alors que
le virus est peut-être à l'elysée son
directeur de cabinet qui est en
confinement laval d'ailleurs de la miss
maison bien madame belloubet et puis
l'assemblée nationale cinq députés
aujourd'hui donc les institutions les
grandes entreprises
le pdg d'air france aussi lui qui a le
coronavirus adp adp parce que j'avais
des frères france non c'est la dp voilà
c'est bien lui donc on est on est dans
une crise qui touche tout le monde le
virus finalement n'est pas un virus de
classe ça c'est quelque chose qui
effectivement
change la donne et puis on voit que un
lundi noir sur les bourses et l'europe
se réveille il a fallu ce lundi noir
pour que finalement en dise ah mais
attendez on va peut-être faire un truc
ensemble ça fait des semaines que
l'italie est dans une crise sanitaire
exceptionnel on n'avait pas entendu
madame von der leyen
alors que le pays était entièrement
fermée hier que les morts s'accumulent
est et qu'il y avait vraiment rien sur
le l'agenda sanitaires parlons de la
grèce laissé seul également pour
défendre la frontière commune face au
lâchage de migrants d'erdogan là non
plus à part une petite vidéo pour dire
que c'était le bouclier de l'europe et
qu'on est que derrière la commission
était tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui
faisait pas vraiment dead
finalement c'est un peu un va-tout ça
fait dix ans sur parle de la crise
humanitaire crise migratoire
on est maintenant dans une crise sociale
qui dure depuis plus de trois ans va
dire une crise démocratique une crise
économique une crise sanitaire les
crises s'accumulent et la réponse
européenne
eh bien il est toujours dans l'urgence
il n'y a pas vraiment alors là on voit
une collaboration d'un seul coup
maintenant on va débloquer 100 millions
pour la recherche mais la recherche
s'est plaint en fait que lors de la
crise du h1n1
les budgets ont été coupées finalement
une fois que l'épidémie était passée
alors que si on avait gardé ses budgets
aujourd'hui on aurait peut-être déjà une
réponse tout à fait
planifiée à ce problème là donc cette
réponse un peu brouillonne dans la crise
parce que crise économique d'abord on
voit que le discours d' emmanuel macron
il est aussi importance dans le volet
économique et boire plus que sur le
volet santé donc c'est bien mais ce sera
ça c'est alors on va se retourner vous
reste évidemment avec nos élections là
on va se retourner vers le docteur
clément photos seins je le disais qu'ils
travaillaient la pitié salpêtrière alors
vous docteur vous êtes véritablement au
coeur du réacteur au contact des malades
qu'elle est actuellement la situation
dans les hôpitaux
absolument on est sur le pont depuis
plus de six semaines actuellement
le premier malade est arrivé chez nous
le 28 janvier et on voit depuis deux
semaine un afflux de patients
je les points soulevés par le président
sont
primordiaux je reviendrai sur les trois
points la recherche
le ralentissement de l'épidémie et
l'argent le nerf de la guerre il ya 4
quatrième point qu'on pourra évoquer
c'est sûr que faire voilà que quand on
est citoyen lambda j'ai envie de dire
pour se prémunir
vous dites l'argent le nerf de la guerre
100 millions d'euros pour la recherche
on n'a pas entendu véritablement parler
des hôpitaux en france c'était peut-être
pas l'objectif premier de cette
conférence de presse puisqu'elle était à
l'issue de la réunion des 27 mais vous
vous tenez pour l'instant les hôpitaux
parce qu'évidemment on craint un
engorgement des hôpitaux délits
notamment dans les services de
réanimation on en est pas encore là en
france
absolument comme vous le savez
l'épidémie a commencé alors que les
hôpitaux de l'assistance publique était
déjà dans une situation précarisés pour
certains services exergue et je parle
ici surtout du manque et de la fatigue
du personnel médical sénat le médical et
paramédical donc on avait
les soignants a tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé déjà plusieurs fois pas été
suffisamment entendu là maintenant
évidemment tout le monde est sur le pont
à 100%
voire plus pour lutter contre l'épidémie
et prendre en charge les malades mais le
fait qu'on n'ait pas une situation
stable et robuste avant de
voilà de démarrer cette épidémie c'est
un petit un petit point faible qui peut
justement avec plus de moyens
je pense rapidement ce corps iv de quoi
nous avons besoin pas seulement de
médecins nous avons besoin d'infirmières
d'aides-soignantes nous avons besoin de
secrétaire médicale
nous avons besoin d'assistantes sociales
de psychologues dont nous avons besoin
beaucoup plus de moyens humains et ça
évidemment ça nécessite des financements
nous avons également besoin de place de
locaux et comme vous le dites
beaucoup de patients en situation grave
nécessitant réanimation assistance
respiratoire
voilà on a besoin de place au niveau des
services de réanimation et soins
intensifs alors vous restez avec nous
docteur va poursuivre également sur ce
plateau le décryptage de cette
allocution d'emmanuel micron avec alexis
poulain emmanuel macron qui souligne une
europe unie alors que l'autriche la
slovénie l'espagne en aussi coupe ses
vols avec l'italie qu'on laisse isolé
est ce que c'est une bonne chose selon
vous le signal envoyé par cet isolement
de l'italie alors on pourrait poser la
question à la médecin aussi c'est
peut-être une des solutions peut-être
pour pas propre à gué cette épidémie
c'est une des solutions évidemment on
doit répondre à l'échelle continentale
les frontières ne servent à rien contre
un virus et c'est pas l'aspect
géographique en fait qui fait la
différence entre les pays européens mais
c'est la chaîne du temps c'est à dire
que on est impacté par ce virus mais pas
au même moment ce qui est se passe en
italie c'est peut-être ce qui va se
passer en france dans quinze jours donc
positive justement parce qu'on a un
petit peu pointé du doigt les problèmes
de gestion entre ces régions du nord qui
sont pour la gérer
de manière un petit peu autonome par
rapport au pouvoir central à ce que leur
situation pourrait arriver chez nous
alors peut-être pas parce que la réponse
est plus rapide mais on a ce problème
sanitaire
voilà l'hôpital des années à vouloir
tirer les coup à vouloir fermer des lits
à vouloir faire des bêtes manager
rappelez-vous le dernier discours de
madame bizarre quand elle est ministre
de la santé
c'était pour dire on n'a pas besoin de
plus de lits on a besoin de
gestionnaires de l'île et ben manager
c'est ridicule
on a besoin de personnels de santé ce
qui vient d'être dit par madame c'est
tout simplement on a besoin d'humains on
a besoin d'humains forme et qui
travaille et qui sont là parce que
l'hôpital c'est le bien commun parce que
ça fait des années que la doctrine
européenne néolibérale elle est de faire
le moins d'état et le plus de
concurrence et le plus de priver
possible or en période de crise si vous
n'avez pas d'état c'est l'anarchie et
c'est l'état qui fait qu' on peut sauver
un pays on peut sauver des citoyens et
est aujourd'hui c'est la limite de ce
modèle qui est en train d'être proposé
mais comme je disais limites mais à tous
les étages sur la gestion sanitaire sur
la gestion humanitaire sur la gestion
économique et on a un ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire qui découvre
que finalement on peut encadrer les prix
que ce n'est pas sale on peut le faire
que finalement la mondialisation est
potentiellement dangereuse en termes de
souveraineté parce que on a plus de
médicaments chez nous parce qu'ils sont
produits en chine
enfin on découvre que finalement tout ce
monde qu'on a construit ces trente
dernières années
et bien c'est une chimère une chimère
extrêmement dangereux extrêmement
volatil parce qu'il suffit d'un petit
virus pour tout faire exploser les
marchés
la solidarité le fait que les systèmes
de santé s'écroule ça maintenant on le
voit et les discours politiques ils ne
peuvent plus faire semblant alors ils
font encore semblant même accro il est
très bon pour ça donc il va parler de
100 millions d'euros
c'est pas assez maintenant combien va
être donné à l'hôpital combien
effectivement c'est pour soutenir
l'économie
il était à necker devant des ambulances
à l'hôpital d'enfants les ambulances qui
faisaient 200 km pour amener les enfants
qui étaient à 200 km du premier hôpital
parce qu'on a fermé des hôpitaux
voilà la situation donc si on veut
investir dans ce pays si on veut faire
en sorte que la solidarité un sens que
l'impôt servent à quelque chose et puis
parlons aussi de cette captation de la
pièce de dire il
falloir que les riches payent oui c'est
même le coeur de la campagne de bernie
sanders
mais c'est bien tout le problème il faut
maintenant organiser la solidarité parce
que c'est la preuve que tout ce qu'on
fait depuis ces années où soi-disant la
concurrence ce serait bien pour les
consommateurs et les citoyens
eh bien oui peut-être pour certaines
choses mais certainement pas pour la
santé la sécurité
docteur clément photo sur les mesures il
n'a pas été question vraiment en détail
des mesures franco française mais je
voulais votre avis justement sur cette
question
les matchs de foot à huis clos les
évènements sportifs les rassemblements
proscrits au delà de 1000 personnes dans
certains endroits
l'école fermée cela vous sans vous en
tant que médecins infectiologues une
bonne et nécessaire solution alors une
réponse un peu longue mais je pense que
c'est important pour comprendre la
première grande pandémie qui a marqué
les esprits s'étaient la peste et elle a
duré deux cents ans plus de deux siècles
de 550 initial afin de 700 alors la
deuxième grande pandémie
elle a duré quatre ans c'était la peste
également
une autre grande pandémie qu'on connaît
mieux et plus récente c'est la grippe
espagnole
elle a duré un gros hiver de 1918 1919
c'est quoi la différence la différence
c'est la mobilité des personnes
c'est également là la pop le nombre de
la densité de population par dont la
densité de population et la mobilité
alors il ya des inconvénients et des
avantages dans les deux cas
l'inconvénient d'une épidémie qui dure
deux siècles c'est qu'elle fait
évidemment beaucoup plus de victimes
pourquoi elle a duré si longtemps parce
que lorsque qu'une personne se déplaçait
de village à village qui de pays en pays
l emmener avec elle la maladie et l
contaminé des personnes qui n'avaient
pas l'immunité s'il a une autre personne
un siècle plus tard revenait dans le
même village elle avait affaire à une
autre génération qui n'avaient pas
l'immunité est de nouveau elle crée une
épidémie avec l'accélération la
globalisation et cetera et cetera
ça va beaucoup plus vite alors
l'avantagé c'est que l'épidémie elle est
forte certes elle va durer moins
longtemps
l'inconvénient c'est que
le fait qu'ils aient beaucoup de
personnes malades en même temps ça ça
surcharge les systèmes de santé et ça
c'est une perte de chance pour les pour
les patients puisque ils sont trop
nombreux et ils peuvent pas être aussi
bien pris en charge que s'ils arrivaient
au compte gouttes
merci en tout cas docteur clément photo
avoir été avec nous en direct d'avoir un
petit peu décrypter cette nouvelle
journée on le disait 33 décès 1780
personnes contaminées dont 86 dans un
état grave
dernière question pour alexis poulain
d'un point de vue un petit peu plus
politique les municipales qui approche à
grands pas dans ces conditions quand on
sait que 28% des français selon un
dernier sondage prend 20 minutes ne
souhaite pas aller vanter en raison de
cette épidémie
sans compter les autres pas très motivé
est-ce qu'on a raison mais maintenir ces
municipales je pense qu'il ya un
calendrier électoral oui on peut les
maintenir
alors après il ya cette problème des
procurations savoir si un directeur
d'établissement comme un ehpad peut
recueillir les procurations de tout
l'établissement
cette circulaire la pose question sur le
droit il ya effectivement la peur du
virus alors on peut faire comme a dit
nadine morano venir avec son stylo pour
signer la feuille d'émargement
on peut choisir ses horaires je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de monde à l'ouverture
peut-être et puis 28% qui ne veulent pas
y aller ça fera juste un de guérir oui
voilà mes mais ça ferait un petit peu
plus d'abstention le problème c'est que
les élections se suivent et se
ressemblent malheureusement il ya
beaucoup d'abstention dans ce pays donc
vouloir les décalés pensant que
peut-être on aurait plus de gens qui
viendraient il ya eu beaucoup d'argent
investi dans les campagnes beaucoup de
temps investi dans les campagnes
c'est là ça arrive ce week end est-ce
que c'est nécessaire de repousser
maintenant c'est ce serait un peu tard
un peu surprenant faudrait vraiment un
énorme pic
effectivement dire c'est pas c'est pas
forcément une bonne idée je la dessus je
sais pas mais ça me paraîtrait un coup
politique dangereux à jouer
effectivement de décaler seniors alexis
on va on va repartir à l'hôpital de la
pitié salpêtrière parce que le docteur
clément photo ce que j'ai remercié
peut-être un peu hâtivement souhaiterait
faire passer un message à nos
téléspectateurs
oui donc les deux points sur lequel je
voulais insister c'était donc
l'importance des moyens pour la
recherche et de pouvoir démarrer le plus
tôt possible les études en sachant qu'on
a évidemment déjà commencé on ne peut
pas faire que du traitement palliatif et
voilà il faut vraiment on a déjà démarré
à des traitements et on étudie au fur et
à mesure et les informations que je
voulais donner aux populations s'est
évité
c'est paradoxal à éviter les systèmes de
santé si vous n'êtes pas très malade
si vous avez des consultations non
urgentes des interventions non urgence
éviter de fréquenter les hôpitaux qui
sont des lieux de contamination on le
sait ça a été montré en chine et l'autre
chose c'est que toutes les personnes
fragiles devraient être vaccinés
maintenant et peuvent encore le faire
contre la grippe et le cnom au coq
personnes de plus de 60 ans personnes
immunodéprimées personnes avec des
maladies respiratoires
voilà j'en ai des gens n'est fini et je
vous remercie effectivement merci le 12
heures clément photo ce parce que c'est
pas un conseil qu'on entend souvent sauf
erreur de ma part un vaccin contre la
grippe actuellement qui le
sous-entendait le docteur pourrait
peut-être protéger contre ce virus
l'élément reste à creuser des vaccins
pneumococciques ne souhaiterait pas
déformer les propos du docteur merci en
tout cas à vous merci alexis poulin nous
avoir accompagnés